♪
>> WE HAVE NOT BEEN AWARE OF
THAT LITERALLY HAD NOT BEEN
AWARE OF WHAT HAD TRANSPIRED.
>>
PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: IT WAS A MAJOR
DIPLOMATIC BLUNDER THE U.S. NOT
TELLING FRANCE OF AN END TO A
SUBMARINE DEAL, A BIG ONE.
DEALING, INSTEAD WITH AUSTRALIA
AND THE FRENCH WERE REALLY UPSET
ABOUT IT SO MUCH SO THEY PULLED
THE AMBASSADOR FROM THE U.S.
THE FRENCH AMBASSADOR TO THE
U.S. OUT.
NOW, THE PRESIDENT SAID IT WAS
CLUMSY MISTAKE.
DIDN'T APOLOGIZE BUT THAT'S THE
FIRST PART OF HIS EUROPE TRIP.
START THERE WITH OUR PANEL BEN
DOMENECH PUBLISHER OF THE
FEDERALIST.
HAROLD FORD JR. CEO OF
EMPOWERMENT AND INCLUSION
CAPITOL.
TREY GOWDY FORMER CONGRESSMAN
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA.
TREY, CLUMSY AND HE DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW ABOUT IT IS WHAT HE TOLD
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT MACRON.
>> YEAH, I'M NOT SURE I WOULD
HAVE ADMITTED THAT EVEN IF IT
WERE TRUE.
I CAN TELL YOU IMAGINE HOW BAD
YOUR LIFE IS WHEN YOU ARE
HAPPIER MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF FRANCE HOW STIFF IN
A SUBMARINE DEAL.
YOU WOULD RATHER DO THAT THAN GO
MEET WITH THE PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS
IN THE HOUSE.
HOW BAD IS YOUR LIFE IF YOU
PREFER THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Bret: LET'S TURN THERE,
HAROLD, WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED
LAST NIGHT ON CAPITOL HILL, THE
PUNT TO NEXT WEEK THERE IS STILL
SOME THOUGHT THAT IT MIGHT BE
TWO WEEKS.
SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING SOME TIME
BEFORE THANKSGIVING WHERE THIS
ALL GETS IRONED OUT.
I MEAN, IT'S PRETTY UGLY.
IT MAY STILL HAPPEN BUT IT'S
UGLY.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON AND I
WOULD AGREE WITH YOU.
IT'S NOT THE WAY, I'M SURE, HE
ORCHESTRATED OR CHOREOGRAPHED IT
BUT SOMETIMES BIG TIME
LEGISLATION IS NOT
CHOREOGRAPHED.
IS NOT CHOREOGRAPHABLE IN THE
WAY YOU MAY LIKE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IF THEY
GET THIS PASSED 1.57 TRILLION.
YOU HAVE 1.2, $1.25 TRILLION
PACKAGE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE,
THAT'S $3 TRILLION HE WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN IN THE FIRST YEAR IN THE
PRESIDENCY.
AGAIN, TO YOUR POINT, IT HAS NOT
BEEN PRETTY.
BUT I GIVE CREDIT TO SOME OF
THE -- A LOT OF PROGRESSIVES,
BECAUSE THEY KEPT THEIR WORD.
I THINK NOW THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER OR NOT SENATORS MANCHIN
AND CINEMA CAN KEEP THEIR WORD
AS WELL AND, IF THEY DO, WE WILL
PASS AN HISTORIC PIECE OF
LEGISLATION, AGAIN, NOT PRETTY
THE WAY THEY DID IT.
WE OFTEN DON'T SEE THIS KIND OF
SAUSAGE-MAKING WE JUST HAPPEN TO
BE SEEING IT IN THIS INSTANCE.
>> Bret: TALK ABOUT NOT PRETTY,
BEN.
THIS STORY THAT WAS FROM THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL," AND NOW
IS MOVING FORWARD ABOUT THE
POSSIBLE PLANS TO PAY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE BEEN
SEPARATED IN THEIR FAMILIES
FINALLY $450,000 OR MORE DAN
CRENSHAW.
BIDEN WANTS TO PAY 450,000
HARDSHIP WHILE BREAKING OUR
LAWS.
FOR PERSPECTIVE, IF A SERVICE
MEMBER IS KILLED IN ACTION,
THEIR NEXT OF KIN GETS AN
INSURANCE PAYMENT OF $400,000.
LET THAT SINK IN.
I'M NOT SURE I BELIEVE THIS
STORY WHEN I FIRST READ IT, BEN.
BUT, THERE HASN'T BEEN PUSH BACK
YET AND WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN AN
OFFICIAL SHOOT DOWN OF THIS
STORY.
>> BRET, AS A PLUSH EVERYWHERE
OF THE FEDERALIST PEOPLE PITCH
ME OCCASIONALLY STORIES.
WHEN THIS ONE CAME INTO MY EMAIL
I REACTED BY ASSUMING THAT IT
WAS NOT TRUE.
I COULD NOT BELIEVE THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WAS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING.
AND, YET, WE ARE SEEING THAT
THERE
♪ PUSHBACK OF THIS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ONGOING AND THE AMOUNT OF
BACKLASH THAT I THINK YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE TO THIS IS JUST
GOING TO BE UNPRECEDENTED.
PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO ACCEPT
THIS AND JUST GO ALONG WITH IT
JUST TO CIRCLE BACK TO HAROLD'S
POINT.
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS DOG'S
BREAKFAST OF A BILL OR A FIRE
FESTIVAL DINNER IF YOU WANT THE
MORE CURRENT RECOLLECTION IS
GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN ACTUALLY SELL TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SEEMS
TO BE GOING DOWN THIS ROAD OF
MEANDERING THROUGH ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT TOPICS THAT ARE OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEN JUST
SORT OF SAYING TRUST US, WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT YOU LIKE WHEN
THEY HAVE NO MAJOR THING, NO
MAJOR THING TO POINT TO THAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND CERTAINLY THE
FACT THAT THEY COULDN'T GET THIS
DONE IN TIME FOR THE VIRGINIA
ELECTION IS SOMETHING THAT
WEIGHS ON THE MIND OF A LOT OF
D.C. DEMOCRATS TONIGHT.
>> Bret: WELL, AND PARTICULARLY
TERRY McAULIFFE IN THE
VIRGINIA ELECTION AND SPEAKING
OF WHICH, FINAL DAYS BEFORE
TUESDAY'S ELECTION DAY, WE SAW
THE POLL THAT WE HAD LAST NIGHT.
BIG SHIFT IN THAT RACE.
NOW, YOU HAVE GOT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS HAPPENING, THE
YOUNGKIN COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR
SAYING THAT TERRY McAULIFFE'S
CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN THE DIRTIEST,
NSAEST MOST DISHONEST CAMPAIGN
IN VIRGINIA HISTORY.
THIS MORNING THEY ARE CLOSING
OUT HIS CAREER BY GOING EVEN
LOWER.
THERE IS THIS MOMENT THIS
MORNING WHERE THERE WERE THESE
GUYS WITH TIKI TORCHES, TREY, IN
FRONT OF A YOUNGKIN BUS SAYING
WE ARE ALL IN FOR GLENN
SUGGESTING HEARKENING BACK TO
CHARLOTTESVILLE AND THE NAZIS
AND THE WHITE SUPREMACISTS WHO
MARCHED IN THAT MARCH.
LATE TODAY THERE WAS A LOT OF
ALLEGATIONS THAT THEY WERE
DEMOCRATS, ACTUALLY.
THE LINCOLN PROJECT SAID THAT
THEY ARE TAKING CREDIT OR SAYING
THAT THEY WERE BEHIND IT.
THE YOUNGKIN PEOPLE ARE SAYING
THEY THINK THEY ARE DEMOCRATS.
BOTTOM LINE, YOU HAVE GOT A LOT
OF STUFF GOING ON.
THEN YOU LOOK AT THIS.
THIS IS A FLIER THAT CAME OUT IN
WHICH YOU WOULD THINK THAT IT'S
YOUNGKIN JUST BEING ENDORSED BY
DONALD TRUMP AND THAT'S A
REPUBLICAN THING AND TRUMP NEXT
TO YOUNGKIN AND THUMBS UP BUT IF
YOU LOOK CLOSELY, ON THE BACK OF
THIS FLIER IT'S THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY OF VIRGINIA AND
SPECIFICALLY THE McAULIFFE
CAMPAIGN THAT REALLY WANTS THAT
TIE BETWEEN DONALD TRUMP AND
GLENN YOUNGKIN.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, BRET, IF PEOPLE
SAY THAT IT WAS DEMOCRATS AND
THE LINCOLN PROJECT, THEY ARE
BOTH RIGHT.
THE LINCOLN PROJECT IS A BUNCH
OF DEMOCRATS.
SO, THIS IS WHY PEOPLE HATE
POLITICS.
THERE MAY BE REASONS TO NOT VOTE
FOR GLENN YOUNGKIN BUT IS HE NOT
A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
SO, THE FACT THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
ON THE VERGE OF LOSING IN
VIRGINIA FOR, WHAT, A FIRST TIME
IN 20 YEARS?
WHEN YOU RUN A CANDIDATE WHO HAS
BEEN AROUND SINCE THE
HAMILTON-AND IS HE A CLINTON
ACOLYTE THAT NO ONE IS EXCITED
ABOUT, THEY -- VIRGINIA
DEMOCRATS FOUND A WAY TO MAKE
THAT STATE COMPETITIVE.
>> Bret: I WILL GIVE YOU THE
LAST WORD, HAROLD.
>> WE WILL DO WITHOUT WINNERS
AND LOSERS BUT YOU HAVE THE LAST
WORD HERE.
>> IF GLENN YOUNGKIN WHO, I
THINK, HAS RUN A GREAT CAMPAIGN
SO FAR WHO REMINDS ME A LITTLE
BIT OF TREY GOWDY AND SOME OF
THE REPUBLICANS THAT I SERVED
WITH WHOM I RESPECTED SO
GREATLY, IF HE DECIDES TO BRING
IN A GUY, WHICH I THINK HE IS
GOING TO BRING IN DONALD TRUMP
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS WHO LOST
THE STATE BY 10 POINTS, MAYBE HE
DOESN'T HAVE IT LOCKED UP YET.
THIS CAMPAIGN HAS NOT BEEN THE
PRETTIEST CAMPAIGN.
BUT WE WILL HAVE AN OUTCOME
TUESDAY.
AND I AGREE IT WILL PORTEND WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IN NEXT YEAR'S
MIDTERMS BUT I WOULDN'T COUNT
TERRY McAULIFFE OUT AND I
CERTAINLY FOR GLENN YOUNGKIN TO
BRING DONALD TRUMP IN IT LEADS
ME TO BELIEVE HE DOESN'T HAVE
THIS LOCKED UP YET.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT